money to this first session in the
external speaker series that we
organized it's an attempt to
bring people working um
it's an it's an attempt to force an
exchange between the people working on
methodological and theoretical aspects
of
causality namely uh all of them or most
of the participants of this program
um with people were coming at it from a
different angle so for instance people
that are working with real world data
trying to distill their causal relations
that are informative for policy makers
so we will have philosophers physicists
engineers and today a political
scientist in this in this series
professor cecilia mo is a political
scientist and
working also on public policy
and um
a recent i will not have not talked much
about
the long list of awards and
achievements which you can find on our
website but i want to say that she's
working on economic inequality and
the relation or the effect of economic
inequality on
political participation
and she's also working on
how can we cultivate uh
democratic norms in the youth
of uh in the youth which will be the
future
future which will be the future
constituents of these democratic
entities and i think those are two very
topical topical
questions especially in this political
climate that we're living in right now
geopolitical climate one might say
so i'm very pleased to welcome cecilia
to give a talk
on recent work on the effect of national
service on beliefs mindsets and life
pathways
i don't want to take care much more of
your time and please join me in
welcoming cecilia
thank you i mean it seems feels a little
awkward having a mic like i feel like i
can use my teacher voice but in any case
uh thank you so much for uh um inviting
me here um i was looking at the speaker
series i was like i do very different
kind of work than the typical speakers
that come through
i do apply to work i often work with
partners that are doing programmatic
interventions to start you know to think
about
how those interventions affect different
outcomes that we might care about which
might be trust in government political
participation voter turnout um things of
that sort so this project is actually um
a kind of a long-standing partnership
that i have with teach for all teach for
all is a consortium of about 50
organizations around the world
teach for america is probably the one
that's sort of best known in the united
states
but it's this group of organizations
that are trying to address issues of
inequality by recruiting recent
graduates to teach essentially for about
two years in low-income communities
and
a lot of the research that's been done
thus far in those organizations are just
more working on well how do they impact
the constituents they serve and the
constituents being really you know
children that they're working with in
the classroom but another part like
really in these service organizations
part of their theory of change is to
affect
the participants themselves right
thinking about well what happens to the
participants and if we recruit to these
young promising graduates who you know
whether they stay in the classroom or go
in like run for office or do other
things
do they then have a different view of
the world that will then lead to
different kinds of policy making
different kinds of career choices and
then just more general civic engagement
things that are problematic in a lot of
democracies currently
um so i'll share sort of different sets
of findings that leverage both
administrative data and survey data um
so these are sort of i think like five
different papers that are pieced
together to just kind of give you a
taste of the different kinds of outcomes
that we've been looking at utilizing the
same kind of causal identification
strategy
um so
basically theoretically right from this
the standpoint of social science like in
terms of why is this interesting to a
person like myself i was interested in
looking at national service because if
we look at the history of national
service it actually begins with a speech
where they paralleled national service
as a moral equivalent of war so what
does that mean
it's a sense that you know during peace
time
right
then
unlike during wartime right like people
are off to war they're like going and
doing something for their country and
like it
incites sort of patriotism and
involvement and sense of duty but during
peace time there was this worry that
people will just become selfish little
egos that don't need to worry about
anyone other than themselves and because
life is kind of calm and then so forth
that we're going to then have a society
of individuals that don't really care
about one another and then that creates
a setting a set of norms that would
compromise things that we need in terms
of a healthy democracy
right so what are national service
programs they recruit promising college
graduates that will be future leaders
right that's one of the features they
tend to put future leaders into contact
with disadvantaged populations right
some some group that needs assistance uh
in the context of some kind of social
ill
and it usually requires intensive
intergroup contact um because it's a you
know you're in that community for a
minimum of about two years
as i said um national service was likely
to uh to be the moral equivalent of war
so here's this one quote um so from that
speech in 1910 william james argued that
youth service is the moral equivalent of
war and could be a mechanism by which
the gilded youth that would have
healthier
would have healthier sympathies and
sober ideas and that through service a
stable system of morals of civic honor
builds itself up so there's all these
claims that are being made
um but
it's not really been empirically studied
right in an intensive way like there
have been sort of case studies um
interviews of alumni but that doesn't
really actually
tease out whether or not these programs
are having the desired effect one could
sort of think that there's just
selection bias right these organizations
are just basically able to sort out the
individuals in society that would
basically care about
things like civic engagement political
participation to begin with so you don't
want to think that these organizations
are doing anything other than sorting
out the types of individuals that have
have certain kinds of values
and right now there's a lot of
discussions around sort of reinvesting
in national service programs
so in light of covid there's been
discussions around a pandemic response
and opportunity through national service
act right investing in opportunities to
try to grow national service as a way of
actually you know
cultivating some healing post pandemic
um within political campaigns you know
prominent uh candidates like pete
boudejaj like they actually like ran on
a platform saying that they're really
going to increase and create a larger
network of national service programs
and in california and uc berkeley
recently signed on um
governor gavin newsom just created this
california for all college corps and uc
berkeley is one of its participants to
try to create debt-free pathways to
increase service
for for college students so discussions
around how to maybe use national service
as a way to kind of respond to some
problems that have arisen in terms of
student debt around polarization around
people not caring for one another and so
forth
so in terms of the theory of change from
the social science standpoint like we've
you know explored a lot around the
contact hypothesis and what happens when
people just come together turns out it's
not so easy all kinds of contact isn't
necessarily good
there's been work like say from like bob
putnam who speak who spoke to if you
have a lot of people who are different
from one another kind of just hang out
you actually see breakdowns in civic
engagement breakdown and trust just
because they're people that are just
bumping into one another that don't
actually know one another and so
what is necessary are more deep
prolonged opportunities for contact
which then allow for
this opportunity to have what they call
sort of friendship potential right to
actually hear each other's stories
um and there's other work that speaks to
how context matters a lot right having
contact one with one another in like
segregated highly kind of hostile
settings is going to be very different
than in a context where you're trying to
help one another so in say like a
service context uh that's going to be a
very different context in which people
are coming together
the other feature of why i thought that
national service is really promising is
that it's actually targeting people at a
very critical juncture right it's during
young adulthood um and that's viewed as
a time in like sociology as like the
place in which political
the the time in people's life histories
where politicized identities and a sense
of group interest really start forming
um so
that sort of period seems prime for
seeing uh the effects that one might
want to see
so the idea is like if you then marry
kind of these people who are kind of
malleable
with organized action material social
and cognitive resources for support and
an opportunity to participate and adjust
cause you might actually start seeing
things that you would desire increased
civic engagement increased sense of
political efficacy and participation
with an ethic of concern for the welfare
of others which is ultimately you know
what we normatively want to see
so research questions so what are the
impacts of youth national service
programs and democratic citizenship that
was sort of the larger question that
i've been asking and you can think about
well when you're thinking about impacts
how might it affect attitudes right just
like views how might it actually
change like tolerance levels of
prejudice
how might it change behaviors as it
relates to civic and political
participation how might it change your
life trajectory in terms of what careers
you choose to pursue
and then what effect might it have in
terms of how you assess policy reform
so in terms of the data that i leverage
um so this is like i said this has been
a partnership with teach for all so uh
most of my findings so far from teach
for america as it's the most mature
organization uh so it was leveraging the
2007 through 2015 cohorts 2007 it was
the moment in which there was this
really nice feature that developed
within teach for america which is their
selection process um involved having a
threshold score
so um with these programs it's really
difficult to do sort of that gold
standard rct you're not going to
convince an organization to just
randomly admit people into their
programs because usually institutions
think well there's a certain kind of
person that we're looking for to to make
sure that they're going to do the kinds
of service that we want them to do so
randomization is off the table
but tfa
has been a highly selective organization
inviting something like 50 000
applications in any given year for about
3 000 spots
and during those cohorts for 2007-2015
120 000 upwards of that number
made it to sort of the final stage of
the interview process so these are
people that were close to being like you
know they were they were viable for
being admitted and so those are the
individuals that i really targeted for
the study teach for india has a similar
process but a lesson for organization so
it has smaller sample size and same for
teach for australia
so i married
this
data set
with
a survey an original survey that i
collected back in 2015 that was open for
about six months
that had various questions around these
dimensions that i outlined as core to
the study um and
within our world we're constantly
looking to try to increase response
rates
generally with targeted samples you're
not able to achieve a response to more
than about 10 percent um but with high
levels of incentives and things of that
sort we're able to get about a quarter
of those that we targeted to actually
respond to the survey
um correlation causation right i just
said you know we worry about selection
bias like that's the core thing
which is uh why we want to try
leveraging um a quasi-experimental
design um to to tease out causal effects
so for the quasi-experiment analysis
most of my findings are using the rdd
approach and teach for india we had to
use a genetic matching strategy
to try to
to estimate causal effects because their
threshold was compromised
in the sense of interviewers actually
knew the threshold so if interviewers
know the threshold then you might start
seeing gaming of interviewers in terms
of trying to have scores that are higher
for those who like right above the
threshold if you really want them to get
in um so certain assumptions don't hold
and suffer teach for india we tried
looking at
effects using a genetic matching
strategy but for the rd approach
we need to have that first stage right
like a nice discontinuity in terms of an
increase in probability of being
admitted at that threshold score and
that's what we see about a 30 percentage
point difference right at that threshold
of um the probability of being granted
admission this is not a sharp
discontinuity it's probabilistic as
those below the threshold might be
reconsidered
because of some other
feature of their
of their application right
for instance the teach for america is
really trying to recruit more men of
color right because there's a really low
number of well generally the the skew is
that what teachers are it's majority
female and then if you think of how many
among the few men that go into the
teaching profession how many of them are
men of color
it's very small and at least within the
education setting in terms of student
score outcomes the lowest performing
kids are
boys of color and so there's sort of
prioritization of men of color so you
might have some that are below the
threshold that are ultimately granted
admission because there's like other
features to consider and then there
might be those who are above the
threshold that there might be some other
things going on that ultimately to
decide not to admit that person yes go
ahead just a quick clarification the
admissions score i'm just naive to what
i don't know what that is are these
academic
features or
what what goes into that sort of score
yep that's a good question um so the
teacher for american admissions i think
think a lot about like college
admissions or uh graduate admissions
there's letters of recommendations there
might be transcripts there's submitted
there's personal statements and then
there's interviews so those who make it
through sort of the initial review based
upon just what they submit on paper
are then going to be interviewed with
individuals just to sort of talk about
um you know why they want to join teach
for america and then they're also asked
to do
a teaching sample where they're asked to
do just a demonstration of a lesson
to show that if you're in front of a
classroom in front of kids like can you
teach something so you're asked to do
like a 15-minute demo
so those are all the things that go into
this admission score which is a weighted
average of all of these dimensions
that
importantly the interviewers don't know
about and no one other than a small
group of individuals in admissions team
like know actually the threshold score
which then allows for us to take
advantage of this because no one is
gaming this process because no one has
any idea if the cup point is at 50 60 65
like no one knows that
so that helps us
know that certain assumptions that need
to hold to really be able to leverage an
rdd analysis um and holds and you know i
think with the regression discontinuity
approach that's something that many of
our colleagues um
emphasize that the
kind of qualitative work is really
important because you have to know a lot
about the process to actually know
whether or not those assumptions hold
right so it means actually talking to
those individuals and like seeing the
admissions process so for this
i actually shadowed an emissions team
and saw just to make sure that certain
things that i think needed to hold like
were actually reflected in reality um
so yeah so that's so the admission score
is a running variable here and then the
cutoff um
is some arbitrary number and it changes
and then it changes from year to year so
we standardize the year um to have zero
be the cut point um across each of the
each of the
each of the cohorts
so for the first study this is really
looking at um attitudinal shifts and
this is from a paper that was published
in 2018 that was looking at you know how
are they viewing um
how are they viewing things around like
you know why are people poor like are
people of color like less deserving of
assistance
and so what i did see is that there's an
increased perception that there are
really huge issues in terms of our
political system
that there was a tendency to have
external features be emphasized more as
opposed to internal like what i mean by
that is as opposed to blaming people for
being poor they're more likely to say
it's actually systemic issues that are
causing issues of poverty and less about
say a person being lazy or um you know
thoughtless or you know any of those
things where it's just blaming traits
around the individuals and things that
we do here in the narrative like oh my
goodness we cannot give out welfare
programs because they're just going to
go and buy a phone or like waste it on
alcohol right like those that kind of
view is more focusing on internal
attributes and blaming as opposed to an
external sort of circumstances of like
the structure makes it impossible for
people who are poor to get out of
poverty
and then also evidence that there was
decreased prejudice and the effects were
durable in the sense of we're looking at
some of these effects when they are nine
years out of the program right so this
is not just two weeks after or a day
after these are seeing are the effects
present a month after a year after two
years and up to nine years after and we
find that that is true which is really
nice to be able to see as a lot of
studies especially those in psych where
they're doing kind of laboratory studies
they're doing they're looking at effects
that tend to just be within a very short
window of time and long term is within
months as opposed to years yes go ahead
quick clarification when you say if you
mean effects uh comparing participants
to non-participants but not
participants to their prior
um it's not within subject change it's
across that's that's right so we're
comparing those who are barely admitted
to those who are barely rejected so it's
a very localized treatment effect right
so then there's those trade-offs so like
you you can get that internal vial
internally valid estimate but then it's
actually very localized to those that
are just above the cutoff and below we
can't externalize to those who are even
like broader within the sample and
obviously we are only looking at
those who applied right so if we
actually look at a sample if somehow you
convinced people who wouldn't be
inclined to volunteer to do these
programs when we see similar effects and
the answer is like we can't actually
generalize from this
i have a question about dan's question
so
so you're saying
what you're do like i understand that
that's what in fact she's doing with the
research design but isn't the point of
it is to make these counterfactual
claims about
individual subjects i mean the point of
it is to be able to say
like if the marginal dan
dan
like had it done teach for america he
would have been more of a right-wing
[ __ ]
like i mean so as i understand that like
because of the fundamental problem of
causal inference and all this stuff like
we have to do it this way but isn't that
the point of it is to make that
individual level well i i mean this is
like a long
debate i guess but like it's dangerous
to
i think draw those kinds of conclusions
from these kinds of local
treatment effects because they're
they're like we don't know anything
about how the person like what the
person's attitudes or reviews were
before they entered the program
so it's not really about how they
changed as a person but it's like how
much does program participation
like how do program participants change
from program applicants who are not
participants
yeah i'm sorry i mean maybe this is just
but again it's like i understand that
you have to do it this way because we
only have data
about two different groups of people but
that's the reason we call it causal
inference is because we think that what
this data is telling us is like if a
particular person hadn't done this
someone that already had this propensity
to to engage in it
that they would have been slightly less
empathetic or civically minded
i mean like otherwise why why not just
look at two different people and just
make it a statistical claim
i mean again like i understand that that
and i think and again like the local
average treatment effect seems to be
conceptual here not just like a matter
of external validity because
what would it even mean to like right
you know the whole point is to
isn't if this is an institution that is
selective you're not asking about an
institution that's that's the draft
you're asking about an institution that
is selective so it seems to me that
conceptually you want to limit it right
i mean i'm asking i'm asking the speaker
wouldn't i mean it's not the case yeah
but i mean like if we say i mean we are
actually going to do a study that
follows up individuals to look at within
individual change but even then like
that's not actually a better design
that's just you know trying to get like
illustrative like do we see kind of
consistent patterns and maybe there
might be differences depending on the
type of individual
right because every person is still
different right so like some
participants might actually be coming
with
greater um
[Music]
greater
knowledge around like what it feels to
be poor because they themselves grew up
in a family with like food stamps and
things of that sort right so all we have
is just more of an average of like the
kinds of individuals that tend to be
barely admitted versus the average of
the type of people who don't
that were barely rejected and we're just
comparing the averages like we can't say
anything about
sort of dimensions of people and how
that might make effects larger or
smaller and so the heterogeneity is is
not able to be
sort of assessed here in terms of what
are the dimensions of the person like
all we have is sort of this averaging of
like all of the people who like happen
to be barely admitted and the average of
all the people who are fairly rejected
and from that at least being able to i
think you know
it's fair to still be able to say like
we can still infer like if it's a if
it's a positive or a negative effect or
if it's an effect that seems to be
notably large versus small in relation
to other studies that are similarly
using either ircts or
quasi experimental designs um but yeah
we're not like we can't actually say
anything about like a specific type of
person here but i don't think that's
what we want to do here when we're
trying to estimate programmatic effects
i'm sorry i actually i i i promise it's
the last question on this but it seems
to me that you do want to say something
both about a particular type of person
because
you do like you want to say something
about people who apply to teach for
america not about you know the
population at large
and second like it just seems that
there's that if you
the the fact that it's a very localized
treatment effect just seems conceptual
right i mean
it's just it is a different treatment to
randomize people to teach for two years
than it is to select people who have
applied to teach for two years so why
would we want
to to know about i mean it's just it
seems like that's the research question
it isn't a research question about the
effect of randomizing people to teach
right
we could you know actually argue that
the facts that we get from this kind of
design might be conservative estimates
and we can sort of think about whether
or not it's a conservative or
non-conservative estimate because if i
look at sort of the the graphs of like
where opinions are among those who are
um just
to this to this side of the threshold
i mean there there's and a lot of the
outcomes they care about there is sort
of like an upward slope so one could
argue like maybe if we did randomize
among the people that are here like the
effects could be bigger but then you
could also say like maybe the effects
could be smaller and that's an open
question um
so
the the answer that i have for you is
more we should look at heterogeneity and
then it's not actually obvious to me
whether or not what we have is a
conservative or non-conservative
estimate and i think that's sort of a
theoretical question of like what do we
think that this like looking at the
localized average treatment effect is
that going to be a conservative estimate
and i can make arguments that it it
should but there's also arguments i can
make for that might actually not be a
conservative estimate um so
there's
in trying to
get some causal like causal purchase
like there are still things that we're
not able to fully clarify in terms of
heterogeneity but we couldn't do so so
we did do some effects of just like
looking at subgroups like if we look at
just like women if you looked at just uh
white participants if we looked at just
participants who are older like do we
see different patterns
and generally we don't and so like that
gives us some sense that this is kind of
you know across different demographic
features you might still see similar
patterns um but i can't say like you
know if it's going to be smaller or
larger and all of that and that's still
kind of up for debate i'm like even how
i wrote this paper i was like might be
conservative it might actually be
smaller i don't know um because the the
way that i say that it could be
conservative is for the those who are
applying for this organization they are
not
as you said sort of like right wing
like they're not the white supremacists
who are applying for these programs
right but like if they were to do like
there are people that are already
probably answering in very progressive
kind of empathetic ways so then there
might be a ceiling effect and so like
they're already kind of mostly there so
then the effects might actually be kind
of smaller and if we took people who
weren't mostly there there's more
there's more space for them to grow
but then there might also then be a
reason to believe those who are not
inclined to apply they're not open to
change and so you can do all of this but
they're just going to be resistant and
doesn't actually matter so there might
be a smaller change so there's
there's arguments for thinking that this
effect that i have is smaller like might
actually be larger if we like looked at
kind of everybody um and then did like
the gold standard study but it might
also be smaller and the answer is like i
don't know but what we have is at least
this localized average treatment effect
conditional upon people who are
interested in applying
yeah i think i guess correct me if i'm
wrong but i think from the policy
uh
my understanding of the sort of policy
relevance of of the kind of local
average effect and i don't know if this
helps answer yes's question but like you
have to start off with this idea about
like what's the population that the
program is available to it's like the
population of applicants to this program
and then there's something about like
the average
um empathy beliefs
post program
and you can imagine like what would be
the different won't be the new average
empathy beliefs in that population if i
were to like shift the
threshold for admission down and
therefore admit more people
right so it's like if i had changed the
program to include more people from this
larger population will be the average
empathy
um
you know uh empathy change but it has to
be very local changes to the threshold
that's right i don't know if that is
helpful
so just like some illustrative like
basically if we look at questions so
this sort of gives a sense of the
language so it can just read things like
level of respect for u.s political
institutions or a sense that citizens
basic rights are protected by u.s local
system
you're basically seeing about a ten
percentage point drop so all the
questions were
recoded to be between zero and one it's
about a ten percentage point drop and um
when we the questions that i use for
questions that are present in things
like the america's barometer or the um
world value survey so you can sort of
benchmark like how do germans respond to
these questions or how do those in
korea respond to these questions just to
kind of get a sense of
when you see a 10 10 percentage point
drop is that significant or is that
pretty small um it tends to be that it's
actually pretty large like when we're
comparing just like responses um to
these types of questions across
different countries um and when we're
asking questions around like
contributors of education and equality
as i said earlier it's a sense of like
less blaming so things like um do poor
do you agree or disagree that poor
families don't value education as much
as richer families so things of that
sort of like how are you agreeing or
disagreeing with questions like that uh
to get a sense of what do you think
contributes towards um
low-income students not performing as
well
go ahead
just also clarification so
one the first two questions don't seem
to have anything obviously to do with
teaching
uh so i'd be curious
what you think is going on there
and the second is
uh about the numbers of the uh
of
the
magnitude of the change
is there any sense of what sort of other
interventions
achieve similar or larger change so uh
like i don't have a good scale to think
about how how big of a impact this is
yeah um so these first other questions
around local institutions um
i mean teachers are
about 20
of state and local government employees
right like in terms of public school
teachers so when they're going into uh
the classroom they're still government
employees
and what they are seeing is how the
school may or may not be functioning
well right so you go in and you might
see okay so these kids are expected to
learn and yet they have outdated
textbooks or their chairs are falling
apart or i see
other teachers in the school that are
reading a newspaper in the back of the
room as opposed to doing instruction
so when you start seeing those things
you might start quibble with
actually is this is this education
system working in the way that it's
supposed to as that's a major public
good that the governments provide like
health education things of that sort
right so being a teacher in a poorly
poor
in a dysfunctional school right these
aren't the excellent schools by design
tfa is assigning teachers to schools
that are kind of desperately needing
teachers because they are experiencing
lots of teacher turnover or not able to
actually recruit people to come into
classrooms um
so
that that's that's where i see like it's
it's um not a reach to think that you
might just be disappointed with how
political systems are functioning
because you're actually seeing the lack
of services that children um
in poor communities like just like the
the level of services are just not
acceptable right so that's that's where
i would um not i'm not surprised that
you're seeing the shift that uh shift in
disappointment and in terms of that 10
percentage my bump um change um i could
say like it's i think it's about a third
of the difference of um how haitians
would answer those questions versus
americans would answer those questions
and if you're looking at a country
that's sort of like a failed state where
the government is really imploding
right so a third of that difference of
like how haitians view their government
versus americans like it's it's not
trivial which is why it's useful for
um folks like us who are you know using
survey measures to even have their
problematic questions and like i get
this question of well that question
wasn't really good like why did you use
it there's that tradeoff of like well i
can use a better question or i can use a
question that's been asked readily
around the world and at least by asking
that question that's been asked i can do
some benchmarking to get a sense of are
these large or small magnitudes hence
our choice to pick you know maybe
somewhat imperfect but questions that
have been asked around the world for
many many years to be able to benchmark
um
ask different questions around this is
what we call um
these are things around just class and
income
so you know the government as opposed to
individuals should take more
responsibilities to ensure that everyone
is provided for
income should be made more equal as
opposed to unequal
to incentivize individual individual
effort and again here we're seeing
shifts uh where it's in the direction of
causing people to um
have beliefs that are more situation
environmental factors are important as
opposed to blaming individuals who have
poor outcomes
in terms of these effect sizes um
they're about like the half the
difference of um how say like germans
would answer those questions
so when i say german it's because
germany it's because germany is a place
with a much
much more robust social safety net um
than in the us where it tends to be like
you know you gotta pull yourself up from
the bootstraps um so
in terms of sort of trying to
contextualize these magnitudes but
everything is um consistent in the
direction of
blaming
the system as opposed to individuals
and then there are a set of questions
that what we use in american politics or
these like racial resentment questions
of do you um so it's things like do you
agree that black should overcome
prejudice without special favors or gray
that uh it's really just a matter of
blacks working harder to be just as well
off as white so these are questions that
are asked regularly in the american
national election study to get a
pulse of how
racist americans are
and so what we see is a drop in racial
resentment
and that drop is about in terms of the
size half the difference of how african
americans would answer these questions
versus white americans so again like not
trivial magnitudes
and a general
sense of you know being less satisfied
with how all minority groups are treated
those are all self-reported measures um
so we also did the skin color iat so
this is something that was developed by
those in psychology where you're just
kind of
categorizing pictures with words
so it's harder to blame just to kind of
get a sense of how much more do you
associate say you know people of color
with negativity with negative terms as
opposed to whites with negative terms
and so when we see that
we see that there's a drop
in sort of a marginal drop in um skin
color bias as measured by the skin color
iat um and the this point one two one is
about the difference of how hispanics
would
would do on a skin color iit versus
white individuals
there's not real change in terms of
feeling closeness to minority groups
about 90 percent of the student
population that tfa participants work
with are kids of color um so that's why
we asked questions around feeling
closeness to blacks or hispanics however
the assignments are actually pretty
different so if you're assigned to rio
grande valley
like almost 100 of your students are
hispanic they're not african-american
but if you're assigned to detroit
then you're really not working with
hispanic students you're working with
african-american students so we start
separating out the um
the admits of based upon assignment to
like what communities you're assigned to
you see that the kind of larger effects
are you you see an increase in affinity
to people of color of like black
hispanics separately when you're
actually assigned classrooms where the
majority of your students are are of
that group
um so significance of findings um this
was something that a lot of uh those at
least in my uh political science and
public policy world that was remarkable
as it turns out it's really really
difficult to have people um feel closer
to others like polaroid
increasing polarization is a lot easier
than decreasing polarization and like
getting more perspective taking is a lot
more is really difficult these things
are not easy to move so to be able to
see evidence of some movement
is is one that was sort of viewed as as
good news and one that justifies maybe
that government
and nonprofits should be investing more
in these national service tech programs
let's go ahead
uh relating to all of the treatment
um
earlier you mentioned that you have you
can actually detect very long-term
effects right over
eight years so the treatment effects
that you have shown us are those
short term
it's average
yeah so it's an average if you take
everyone that um
that like in terms of the alumni it
would have been up from six months up to
nine years distant from the program so
this is an average so if i like mapped
out
just like by alumni group
in some cases it's pretty steady in
other cases you actually see the effects
getting larger and i think the reason
why the effects are getting larger for
some groups is that
say you you have this change
and then you decide well i'm also going
to marry someone that is
you know person that's of a different
background i'm going to live in a
community that is more diverse i'm also
going to choose jobs that are so like if
you start making a
other decisions after the short-term
effect that keep on compounding these
effects it's not it's not um kind of
unimaginable for these effects to
actually be getting larger over time so
it depended on the question but it was
either kind of like pretty sticky or
actually in some cases the effects were
getting larger over time but all the
things that are reported it's just
clumping all of them together
as with rdds it's very
it's very sample hungry right uh because
you are really only focusing on those
who are close to the cutoff so it turns
out like you actually need a lot of
people there to to be able to estimate
effects
[Music]
so
none of the things that i reported are
behaviors
these are self-reported questions so
something that is
that i'm working on right now
is
uh does it actually catalyze greater
political engagement so i told you that
people get more disappointed with the
system but they're more empathetic in
terms of people of color and those who
are low income
do they then become sort of ostriches
putting their head in the sand and going
like okay the world sucks i'm just gonna
withdraw or the world is terrible i need
to do something about it right
so what we did was we merged our uh the
teach for america's administrative file
with uh actual voting records
um so actual voting records are things
that you know are there it's um and so
groups like data trust um
they collect all of those records to be
able to kind of keep tabs on who are the
people who are actively voting this data
tends to be leveraged a lot more by kind
of campaign consulting groups right to
just like help candidates know where
they should be allocating the resources
because they want to really target those
who are going to show up to the ballot
box as opposed to those who are you know
not really interested so we merged our
file with administrative records of
voting
and we matched based upon permanent
address
college location state current location
state from the survey and then name and
birthday to be able to find the right
sally smith born in 1982 or whatnot
right um so
the
the the merging endeavor was not trivial
but we did that and uh the quality of
the data trust data is is pretty high
we were able to get this courtesy of my
co-author john holbein who was at byu
and was able to get approval from mitch
romney and so we were able to get this
data via mitch romney because data trust
is actually what the republican party
uses to to contact their voters um so so
that's what we're using and that's what
the republican party is using so it's
sort of as reliable of data as one can
feasibly get as it relates to people's
voting records
um and so what we're seeing is right at
that cut off if we're just looking at
you know the running variable and just a
simple graph what's really nice is that
you can actually see a clear pattern
right at that discontinuity that
something happened like so you know
before i even so with the fuzzy rdd
right like you're scaling your reduced
form value with your first stage don't
even have to do any of that you're
seeing that
right at that cutoff we're seeing a jump
in terms of the likelihood of voting in
elections
so i was really excited to see this
because
at least in this country youth
participation is abysmal
here it is so if we look at how each of
the generations the silent generation
boomer gen x and millennials the rate at
which they were voting when they're 18
to 24 to like 45 to 49 you see an upward
trajectory and likelihood of voting as
you age but then you're also seeing that
with each generation you're seeing this
intercept shift so the the trend is that
with each generation
the propensity to vote is going down
um so
that creates problems uh as it relates
to representation it basically means
that um those who we elect are more
reflective of those who are older of
what they want as opposed to those who
are young right and then who's going to
sort of inherit the policy preferences
the youth right they're going to have to
live with the decisions that are being
made right now for a much longer period
but their participation rate is much
lower
and when we're looking at the turnout
gap between those who are older versus
younger across a range of democracies
the the us has um
is amongst the highest in terms of
having an age gap in in turnout so we
have a serious problem in this country
as it relates to the youth
under um
like not coming out to vote and then the
older folks coming out to vote in a
robust way
so
and why we are focusing on like this as
a context about 80
of those who apply to these national
service programs tend to be
like just out of college right so for
looking at things like peace corps
america americorps programs teach for
america they're mostly recruiting on
college campuses so 80
of those who apply are like college
seniors and then there's another set of
people that might be like one or two or
three years out of college
but they're they're of the kind of 18 to
24 variety right that the typical
profile is about 2122. um so
trying to get this group and seeing does
this program actually lead them to have
greater turnout and it turns out that it
seems like that's the case and getting
them to turn out once is
is
is important because you could ask like
well this is just turning out you're
looking at two elections like we looked
at the 2014 and 2012 elections
um we didn't look at historical
elections because in this country states
purge voting records so it means that
the out like elections from many years
ago that data is not entirely
correct because people were purged out
so you want to look at more of the
recent elections because that's going to
be most accurate
but voting tends to be habitual and
sticky so just getting them out once is
is kind of getting them almost there for
them being kind of voters that are going
to readily readily turn out getting them
just there once is going to be enough to
maybe propel them to be folks who are
voting at a fairly regular
basis because voting is habitual
yes go ahead can i ask a question i'm
sorry i have to leave a little earlier
than i wanted to but
can i ask why so
why is the selection story bad and we
started off your story your talk by
saying like we don't want it to be the
case that
what these institutions are doing are
just selecting we want to show that
there's a causal effect and you know you
look at this and someone could say
you know that's perfectly compatible
with the following story
this institution is just really really
good at selection like there is no
counterpart it's like the nobel prize
like you i don't know what you mean when
you say like what would have happened
if you know would they have gotten as
many sites that they had done the nobel
prize because they just wouldn't have
been as good like the best person just
gets it and what this institution is
doing is just selecting the people that
are going to be
you know and and but i don't understand
like why and this is like a genuine
question to someone that's engaged in
this type like why do we have to why do
you have to make the claim that there is
this causal effect why not say
yeah it is the institution
it's good for us to fund that i don't
have to tell you a counter factual story
where if they hadn't participated and
teach for america they wouldn't have
become a more civically minded person
you know like we should just fund things
that are the mechanisms by which people
that have a propensity to become good
civic
actors
that they that they do there is no like
i mean
what's wrong with that i don't think
anything is wrong per se i think it's
helpful to know both right so like what
this actually figure tells you is
like as they get higher scores you're
also seeing kind of like an upward slope
so it does seem like
whatever tfa is using in terms of their
weights and whatnot
those who are getting for the highest
scores are also the types of people who
are mostly engaged and all of that so
there's something to their selection
process
but then it's also helpful to know that
being in the program itself is also
doing something right like they they are
sorting they are able to like pick out
people to like like let me show you
these are the people that
are of a certain type
they are doing that but it seems like
what they're also doing is that they're
changing those types to be even more of
something that is normatively desirable
from the standpoint of the organization
and from many donors who fund them so i
think it's just helpful to identify that
there's something to how they're
selecting to help us identify the types
of people but they're also causing
people to change that it's not just it's
not just sorting
right so i don't think it has to be
an or it could be an and of like it is
really great to know that they are
selecting on something that means
something like these people are voting
at a higher rate than these folks are
tfa is doing something they're not
trying to find out who's voting more but
in the way that they're selecting
they're somehow able to identify those
who are more engaged
but
there's also something going on right
there which says the program itself is
also doing something just being in the
classroom in and of itself is also
propelling people to have shifts in
views of the world and also shifts in
propensity to do normatively positive
things like vote
um
so
another piece we're also trying to see
if we can um does the this participation
increase political
ambition among underrepresented
populations as the majority of those who
actually apply to these national service
programs as i said were young but
they're also young women
70 percent of those who apply for peace
corps and teach for america are women
and uh there is uh an ambition gap as it
relates to you know when you ask a
typical you know just a college you know
uh woman in college are you interested
in running for office versus a man in
college or there's a big gap just
consistently right in terms of interest
in running for office um and that's due
to a number of things
but there is this ambition gap so when
you then see
um you know if you go into an
organization that tends to be majority
female
you're politically activated right like
you're showing up to the ballot box more
you have these like change in views
are they then more interested in
potentially running for office
um
and you know i don't i think i have to
argue that we have issues of descriptive
representation in this country right um
that only when we look at congress like
less than uh one in five are women and
so using the same kind of design that i
showed you before just leveraging the
rdd with in this case it's a survey
because uh we are
we don't have we
when we look at people who have actually
run for office the numbers are too small
to really be able to say anything so
this is just more like are you even
potentially recruitable like are you
open to even considering it um and
reporting on the survey like yeah i'm
interested in being contacted like yeah
maybe i'd like to be trained by emily's
list to like think about this
we see about a ten point ten point
percentage point increase in like just
interest in participating in um
trainings to to run for office
and when we're looking at women that
the political scientists would call sort
of those with more biographical
availability so those were higher income
unmarried no children right like they
just have more time to potentially sort
of choose
to do something like this we're seeing a
larger effect among women that have
have more economic resources and have
family context in which it's easier to
potentially run for office
and then we see similar effects when
we're looking at just interest in
participating in political campaigns in
general right just in terms of
supporting another candidate
significance of findings right
i just explained before
issues of
of gender ambition is something that we
need to think about and then finally um
i have this paper that's looking at
whether or not policy preferences shift
right like after you go into a program
like this and more specifically an
education policy right there's large
debates around education reform
charter schools privatization do we
do we have high stakes exams should we
pay teachers based upon how well their
students perform all those kinds of
questions do you have different views on
contentious
questions around education policy
and it's interesting because when we're
looking at just descriptive baselines
like when we're looking at how teachers
answer
at policy preference questions as
opposed to non-teachers
the difference between those two groups
are larger than how democrats versus
republicans would answer these questions
or rich and poor would answer these
questions or african-americans and
whites would answer these questions so
there's a really big difference between
how teachers think about what policies
are useful versus non-teachers and this
could again be maybe it's just selection
right like the types of people who
choose to become teachers are just of a
different variety than those who don't
and so their opinions are going to be
different um so leveraging the teach for
america experience given that the
treatment itself is like you have to be
a classroom teacher for two years
minimum
do you actually see changes in how you
view policy
and the answer is yes mainly um so this
was published and at next
and then another paper in public opinion
quarterly uh that the kinds of uh you
know they're attributing differences in
student outcomes um to societal
inequities right that's consistent with
the first paper i showed you so if we
look at like i know the words are kind
of small here but it's it's things like
should we pay attention to policies that
elevate the prestige of the teaching
profession broaden improve access to
wrap around services expand high quality
preschool
allocate school funding based on student
need create a uniform set of national
standards like common core
link teacher evaluation to pay pay link
teacher evaluation and pay
straighten strengthen like unions reduce
dependence on standardized tests expand
vouchers expand high quality charter
schools so if we look at where we're
seeing positive effects it tends to be
where it's
it's elevating the teacher and providing
more resources to schools they're less
interested in things like charter
schools or vouchers or um
teacher pay like that kind of stuff is
less of the point it's more like you
need to just expand the pie grow the pie
in terms of resources that go to schools
um
have have the provision of high quality
public education start earlier right
like start with like the preschoolers
don't have that be something that
parents have to pay out of pocket
and there's actually a drop in interest
in things that are more
market-based reform like
vouchers and charter schools
so
for looking at kind of the range of
policies we do see that teaching in and
of itself does cause some changes in
terms of how you view what are promising
um
levers
and uh
they're not necessarily becoming more
jaded if we're looking at questions of
whether or not they think teachers can
do a lot their optimism around what
teachers can do actually goes up
so
they are
sort of increasing in their respect for
what teachers can accomplish it's more
but they're going to only be able to do
that if they actually have the resources
to be able to do that right
um
and then finally uh right now this i'm
just doing a preliminary study uh
looking at career trajectories and it
does seem like there's some evidence and
this is leveraging both teach for
america and teach for india and teach
for australia results um just to see if
do we see switches
changes in terms of what kinds of jobs
they're choosing to partake in and the
short answer is yes they are more
inclined to pick jobs that are focused
on social
social causes they are more likely to be
in the education sector
they're less likely to be in the private
sector
so that's it i know i shared a lot of
different kind of results but they're
all leveraging the same kind of design
so hope i thought it was okay to kind of
share the full full gamut of things that
i'm looking at so thank you
uh
i have a question about the uh
voluntary aspect of the service so
germany used to have national service
for men that was required where we could
do
service instead of military service
um i don't know about other countries
that might have had that
is there something that gets
is there data available from settings
where it would seem more like a
randomized
trial rather than that you have the
selection of the
so i mean there's previous work
leveraging through the gi bill sort of
like the vietnam draft um in the country
and that was looking at them like
military service and then was no longer
voluntary it's based upon what day you
were born
leveraging a discontinuity but uh still
something that wasn't mandatory and so
then you're it's the full population um
and there you did see kind of positive
effects in terms of this not the same
kinds of outcomes but in things like
sense of duty
uh sense of um kind of obligation and uh
sort of pride in what it means to be you
know an american like there there were
things of that sort like that did change
um so there are a couple studies that
have looked at kind of military because
sometimes it's been compulsive there's
been less looking at like non-military
that is required um so
to the extent that those countries are
willing to show data
and we kind of start looking at this but
there's also um you know so uh
they're like teach for israel also
exists and in israel there is also this
compulsory military service so like
that's a different kind of context so
i'm interested in looking at these
different environments of like what what
actually changes because then they're
doing this voluntary thing after they've
actually already been required to serve
their country in some capacity so maybe
we're not going to see as large of an
effect in those places where like
there's sort of this like
compulsory service and then you know
voluntary service may not do very much
um but context matter but you know to my
knowledge the only other of large-scale
studies have been uh with compulsory
military service
so
i have a conceptual question about how
you think about your discontinuity
so
given that you see this sort of
discontinuity in your
results
do you think that as then
okay if i shift the threshold right
am i going to bump people up
right is that like am i going to change
or is it that i'm just going to do worse
on my selection or
do you now say that look this is under
determined given the data that we've had
i think it's probably underdetermined i
would think like you know if you just
made micro small changes like it's not
really going to affect all that much i
mean as i said the threshold changes
like year to year a little bit so it
might be a little lower might be a
little higher um so like small changes
like i don't think it's going to change
outcomes but sort of like major shifts
maybe because there are different kind
of proclivities going in because teach
for america is like their selection
score is indeed doing something in terms
of
finding out who are the people who tend
to be more empathetic who tend to be
more optimistic who tend to vote at
higher rates like even though they're
not trying necessarily to find those
people they are finding those people so
maybe if you go too low that you might
start seeing kind of different patterns
but it's not they are trying to find
those people right i mean i assume
they're trying to find people more
empathetic they are engaged you will go
the extra mile to teach you know what i
mean who care like i guess that's like i
think when i it's like it seems like it
only has its causal effect because it's
selecting on those traits right like
it wouldn't i don't
i mean they are actively trying to find
these people like that's what you want
in teachers that are going to
be cool
is it just selection or well not just
selection like i'm not like i'm into
selection like i think selection is cool
i'm not like saying like oh it's just
selection like i'm just saying i don't
understand how it could have its causal
effect if it wasn't selecting
like it's dependent upon those traits
being there in to some extent to have
that and so like
it just it that's why i keep saying like
conceptually i don't think that's an
open question like what we don't know is
if we actually did go into a group that
like wouldn't have the inclination we
don't actually have the answer of what
happens if you like just take a person
who is not necessarily interested and
have them and have them do this right
like we don't actually know that so all
i have is like are among those who are
interested
here's the effect and there is an effect
even among those who like you might
think that there won't be an effect
because tfa is selecting really well on
certain dimensions around like empathy
they're not trying to find empathy but
they do ask questions around like you
know what kinds of extracurriculars are
you doing like right like are you active
like are you a high performer like are
you organized like do you are you able
to
actually complete tasks that you say
that you're going to accomplish they
don't ask things like political activism
as it's that you're not supposed to so
in terms of the voter turnout i wasn't
sure if that was necessarily going to
happen um because you're not supposed to
ask about
your party
registration do you vote like you're not
supposed to ask that um
um but
i i actually think like yes there is
selection but i do think that it has an
effect but what we don't know is will it
generalize if we go out to a population
that wouldn't necessarily have the
proclimity to apply to something like
this and so if you expand um so like
there's i'm interested in say like the
california core that the um
that's being invested in now because
there's then a larger group that might
be interested in applying because
they're actually creating a student
debt-free
way
right so then it's like a bunch of
people like i want to do this but you're
telling me if i do this i don't have
student debt so then like it's expanding
the potential population that might be
inclined to sign up for this whereas
like this is it's not doing this like if
anything you're like oh i'm signing up
to be paid lower like i graduate i'm
competitive for going to mckinsey
mckinsey would pay me like 90 000 but if
i do this teaching thing i'm going to
make 30 000
um so so the type of people the types of
people who are willing to do that
because tfa is not um
jerking around it as it relates to its
competitiveness like they're trying to
get those who are competitive for like
top-notch graduate schools getting into
tough consulting um and they even have
partnerships with like goldman sachs and
mckinsey's and so forth to say like they
get into tfa would you be willing to
defer
their contract to like let them do tfa
first so those are the type of people
that they're trying to get but i think
i'm interested in like the california
core world you might be growing the type
of people expanding the type of people
that would be willing because student
like like having no student debt i think
that would motivate a lot of students
but it's still selection i guess all i'm
saying is like those are two different
treatments like a treatment that is that
entails a selection is different than
conscription
like it's not just that we don't know
the causal effect if it was on a
different population like it just is a
different treatment if it's conscription
conscription's not selection
which is great like again i'm not yet
i'm not saying the importance of it i
come from a totally different view from
everyone else here like i'm into
selection i think selection explains
things but i'm just pointing out like
it's a different treatment
but they're trying to separate like
the
selection part with i know i just don't
know if that conceptually makes any
sense
and at least in terms of like you know
when we're trying to do causal inference
most of the time like all we're trying
to do is separate out the selection from
everything else
um so you know it's not to like i think
the selection there is like the
selection stuff is doing something i
think what we're trying to add is it
there's this other part that's also
simultaneously happening so we do want
to attribute some programmatic effect to
like it's not nothing like the act of
being in the classroom for two years
does something but it is only among the
individuals like all we know for sure is
it's only among the individuals that who
are inclined to do this right because
this is not right
why is it even that right so
so
suppose i wanted to say like look all
you're getting is selection here
i might like selection right so i might
think that's great that they select well
but the only difference that i've seen
is that psa selects well i don't see any
sort of causal effect it's just the
difference is due to picking up the
appropriate people
why
on on
what do you say to someone who doubts
that tfa is actually even for those
selected people
can i not run
an argument on this detail just saying
it's only selection and then i might
think that's good or bad
yeah i mean like that that's when the
assumptions are that need to hold as if
it pleats to rdds like we need to test
those things so um what i didn't show
are the various tests and assumptions of
if we look at demographic
characteristics is the running variable
basically smooth and like all the
observables and it is um are there weird
peaks as it relates to density of scores
no it's like a nice kind of smooth
normal curve um do we see biases as it
relates to response rate at the running
variable no it's actually smooth so like
we do want to check all of those things
and then also um do we worry that we are
better able to contact people who have
been admitted because there might be
like better contact information more
current and so this is just uh there's
other things that are wrong right at the
great gate and the answer there was like
no as tfa was really good about
separating its admissions score
admissions data set with like all of the
follow-up data like that they collected
for their core members and their alumni
so like the messiness of the data is
equal for the non-inmates as the admits
are so we do want to check all of those
things to just have confidence that the
the assumptions that need to hold to
actually really leverage and rdd do hold
and in our case it does and then that's
why i also emphasize that it was really
important to do kind of that qualitative
work to see the processes to ensure that
there is no gaming but like all the
things that they were saying around that
this is an unknown cutoff that only only
like a few people know and those people
are not interviewing that those things
are all true um to then give added
confidence that we can actually
like put causal claims on this um
leveraging the rdds
the selection model itself like who's
actually applied to
tfa
i guess it's a data it's a data problem
and then we need to have some kind of
some people
probably
basically
yeah
that's interesting and that is data that
one could get tonight
i haven't thought about it but like yeah
you could actually like map those out
because you can look at any college
campus i think some in some places like
at yale something like
um over 10
of the graduates apply to tfa right so
there's like some institutions that you
can actually look at where it's not that
you won't have you'll have like enough
variation around like those who apply
don't apply to start seeing who are the
types of people um so i don't have the
answer but that is something that could
be explored
i was i was wondering if there's um
work on
the
impacts of that kind of program on the
students and if there's a similar
regression discontinuity in like
classrooms that are
assigned a tfa instructor versus a
regular teacher yeah so at least as it
relates to
the student side there
there have been studies and that's
actually been able to leverage
um an rct
so like with so you can look at sort of
like a school and then if principals are
willing to sort of like randomly assign
so they have a non-tfa
kindergarten teacher the tfa
kindergarten teacher like you can
randomly assign um so they were doing
sort of like random assignments like
within schools between like tfa and
non-tfa teachers to be able to estimate
like our student outcomes different at
least as it relates to like math and
english test scores so studies like that
have been done um so it they haven't
leveraged this continuity in those cases
but it's also it is feasible as there's
uh there's a set of people that apply to
tfa didn't get in
that you know became teachers too and so
there's some things that can do that but
the the gold standard of doing a
randomization has been feasible and so
so while expensive
those kind of studies have been done i
think
there have been three
um that have been done over the course
of the last two decades
thank you very much
you